hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
november 2nd 2020
what is going on oh my god
it is one with 24 hours
away from super tuesday can you [ __ ]
believe it
uh um oh jesus
oh [ __ ] jesus what's gonna happen
are we gonna stick with the orange cut
are we going with fire marshall bill
[Laughter]
i don't know man i don't know
do what you think is right good luck to
you good luck figuring out those [ __ ]
propositions i actually had to call a
buddy of mine
and like cheat my way through and just
be like dude what the [ __ ] does this
mean does
yes me no and maybe means yes and no
means
what the [ __ ] double this thing i don't
understand why it has to be so goddamn
confusing
um but it is what it is and um
you know i don't know the great thing is
it's going to be over tomorrow
that's it you know
everybody can just [ __ ] relax i think
it's gonna be
uh there's just gonna be no middle
ground
half of this country is gonna be
ecstatic and the other half
is gonna be like flipping out
and if the left loses again i mean
nobody cries like the left
um i'm wondering if people on cnn are
gonna start crying again
um i don't know
and then if if if they [ __ ] if he
loses
donald trump loses sorry donald trump
then i think
uh like i said when he becomes a lame
duck
hell had no fury like the dawn scorned
and i figured there's gonna be a lawsuit
and uh
like i said if you live in a blue state
if it went blue
head for the hills of a red state
because he's gonna [ __ ] bring the
orange hammer down
i hate making fun of a fellow ginger but
he's not a real one he sort of became
one at some point i don't know what it
is i thought back in the day he had like
brown hair
i have no idea but anyways this is the
monday morning podcast the day before
the election
um super tuesday and
um which is weird to me i thought when i
was a kid
it was always on november 4th
i always thought the election day was
november 4th
at some point it became november 3rd i
don't know
i don't know why this is the ramblings
of a
uh of an old man here um all right i'm
sort of babbling because i'm trying to
avoid this topic but uh
i gotta i gotta talk about something
here um
i have to uh take a second here to to
talk about travis roy
who unfortunately passed away uh this
past week
uh for those of you unfamiliar he played
hockey for boston university and
unfortunately in a game
um was paralyzed from the neck down
um you know his literally his first
shift
i believe espn did a whole thing on it
and um
you know i was living in boston at the
time when it happened and i'll never
forget the photo that they had in the
paper
the look on his face and then just
trying to put yourself in his position
at his
age the hand that that kid was dealt
um it was just heartbreaking but
the life that he ended up living um
was unbelievable and i only got to know
him
um in the last like couple of years
um we uh i i
reached out to him i'll give you the
quick story i reached out to him in
somewhere in the
late 2000s i said that i was a comic
and then i'm from the boston area and
if you have a foundation or something
you know i would love
if you're ever doing a comedy night just
throwing my hat in the ring i would love
to do
um you know come back and and do a show
so he got back to me and and
said thank you but said just said that
his his um
whatever what the hell's the word the uh
the thing that he set up
the uh the charity organization whatever
the hell you're supposed to say like
his organization basically wasn't set up
yet so i was like all right
and um i don't know i was like okay
so i didn't hear from him from like 10
years and then out of nowhere i just got
an email from him
said hey he's like hey i don't know if
you remember me you reached out
to me in like 2008 i'm like yeah dude of
course i remember you
so he said what were you thinking he
goes i got the foundation up and going
and stuff
i said all right so we ended up doing a
show
at um what was it the wilbur
the wilbur there in boston and
um had a great turnout place sold out
raised a bunch of money and i just
remember uh
you know i was feeling like anxious like
what what am i gonna
like what do i say to this guy um
you know uh like i said just the
randomness
of life the hand that everybody has
dealt
you know why did he get his hand why did
i get mine why did you get yours i just
like what am i gonna say
to this guy and like dude when i tell
you
i met this guy and like he just like lit
up the room
one of the most positive people i've
ever met in my life
and he was funny as hell and was just a
great guy
and i went up and i did my set and thank
god i had a good set nothing like
bombing
at a charity event right and i got off
stage
and um
he asked me like a thousand questions
about stand up was generally interested
he goes that was amazing what a great
set and he was like
how much of that was imp improvised and
i can't remember you know i was riffing
i was having a good time
he goes so you just make making that up
when you're up there
i was like yeah yeah i guess so yeah i
guess so and he's just like that's
amazing
and he really just was he's like do you
realize how amazing that is that you
know how to do that
like and it was so crazy he ended up
like lifting my spirits that's crazy
and um
i don't know i just i i don't know how
to put it into words because i knew him
for such a brief time this was literally
let's see it was last year when i was
doing the movie so that was 2019
we had talked via email but that was the
first and only time i met him face to
face but he had such a profound effect
you know on how like i looked at life
sort of since then i mean i'm not gonna
lie faded a little bit because i'm a
selfish [ __ ] but i definitely
you know when i get like overwhelmed i
got to do this i got to do that i got
the kids what am i doing i'm just like
dude travis roy look what he went
through and somehow that guy was one of
the most positive people
you ever met and it just i don't know it
stuck with me and
i just loved the guy and i was like dude
we're gonna do this every year
and he was like really you'd come back i
was like [ __ ] yeah absolutely
let's do this every year so he was like
great so we were supposed to do it this
year of course the stupid covid thing
happened
so i did make a video for he had like a
he has a wiffle ball game
every year i did make a video to promote
that
but um
you know it's just one of those things
like you know how many times can you
learn the lessons just i just oh i
thought that this was the beginning of
this guy being in my life and and this
great thing that we would do every year
um raise money for this great you know
foundation to help find a cure to build
ramps for people help people get
wheelchairs help people get care all of
that
great stuff and i thought that this was
going to be something that i would do
with him you know for the rest of my
in his life and unfortunately his life
ended this past
week
so
all right sorry
i'm gonna keep doing it so now it's just
gonna be in his memory
all right got through that i had to do
that all right so now let's just talk
bread and circus shall we
geez i'm really going to get emotional i
start talking about how the [ __ ]
patriots are doing here
we actually played all right we played
all right and you know what for half a
second
first of all i thought the bills were
were gonna kick the [ __ ] out of us i
really did because you know josh allen
is for real i know they've had a couple
of you know a little bit of a bumpy
month but like that kid is
amazing and you know they got a lot of
talent on that team
and they've been waiting forever and you
know
it's life right now it's their turn so
i'm thinking like all right here they
come here
they're going to kick the [ __ ] out of us
and i know it was windy or whatever but
i thought we played a really really good
game
that um damien what's
with harrison whoever the hell was that
number 37 out of nowhere all of a sudden
we had like a running game that was
great
we in it right to the end obviously
the tragic fumble on my side but the
great defensive play punching the ball
out in the end
and um you know
the only thing that was bugging me in
that game was the way they were talking
about how the bills had not beaten the
patriots at home
in eight years and that they were
finally gonna do it and at no point were
they addressing
like the fact that like i don't know
i mean tom brady had to leave for you to
do it okay i mean what the [ __ ]
however i had no idea it'd have been
that long
i thought the bills were like the
dolphins where they kind of split with
us every year i had no idea it was like
that so congratulations
to the bills fan it uh the bills fans it
was it was a great game
and uh you guys have a commanding lead
in the afce
obviously i know you guys are thrilled
about that go easy with breaking the
tables you [ __ ] lunatics
i don't know when that started but that
[ __ ] was not going down when i went to a
game
back during like uh when i saw the
bill's jets game i didn't see anybody
doing that [ __ ] now it's like [ __ ]
tough it's off the chats
um who else did i watch i watched
i watched a little bit of the uh san
diego game
and i was taping that and then like an
[ __ ] in the end of the [ __ ] game i
switched i'm going let me see what uh
i want to watch seattle one of my
favorite teams to watch now
it's like let me watch a little the
ending of seattle uh the 49ers even
though the game's out of reach or
whatever
and then i [ __ ] flip back and denver
somehow come back and
won um but i got to tell you i think the
san diego charges
are the future of los angeles football
with the rams good lord what's going on
over there
is it time to hit the panic button in
los angeles
what's the name of that coach the guy
was like the whiz kid and everything but
he also lost a bunch of players you know
todd
gurley got hurt and now he's with the
falcons so
i don't know i think they're like
rebuilding i don't think um
them getting to the super bowl under
that head coach was a fluke they're just
having a tough year it's a weird thing
pittsburgh steelers still undefeated
how about that pittsburgh you got to be
excited about that 7-0
don schuler up in heaven right now still
with the cork on the champagne bottle
pittsburgh says not this week there
donnie
um yeah i watched uh i watched some
football did a bill burt podcast
i had didn't do one last week because i
[ __ ] up my voice but uh
i miss talking to bert as always um
one of the great people i've met in this
business uh my voice feels better my
ears are a little better
they're not ringing as bad i just sort
of just wore earplugs for like a week
give them a break
they kind of settled which is cool
um i had a nice halloween
any you guys did you go out i mean i
know you [ __ ] people who aren't
wearing masks you don't give a [ __ ]
i wish all trumpsters went out as
liberals and they would have [ __ ]
masks on and then maybe this we could
get a hold of this [ __ ] thing
it's under control it's under control
did you guys see some of the clips of
that [ __ ] hbo interview i mean it's
[ __ ] unbelievable
it was a reporter like i'm not going to
let him take control of this interview
and i'm going to try to hold him to task
and there's no way
to do it he will not answer
your questions and he'll just say
but the information here don't look at
that you shouldn't be looking at that
you shouldn't be looking at that you
shouldn't be don't look at you shouldn't
be looking at
i don't know if this that's true but the
[ __ ] reporter
said south korea has had 50 people die
of covid the entire [ __ ] covet
outbreak
all right and we're we're having like a
thousand people die a day
and he was somehow upset with that stat
saying that it was [ __ ] and you
shouldn't look at that
and i don't know i don't know it was
just
as sad as it is it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's it's a [ __ ] sketch
it's literally a sketch but it's it's
the truth
so anyway um
we did like uh a super super super small
gathering of people in our circle and it
was uh
you know it was a great party but nobody
could like interact because we like
had like our masks on and [ __ ] it was
uh but you know we definitely made the
best of it and everybody sort of had
like their little
things of candy that they were going to
give to the kids and you just sort of
set them over there then the kids would
go get them and
i don't know it is it is what it is
trying to do what you're supposed to be
doing out here
and uh i'm up to three pounds with the
shoulder
[ __ ] rehab thing doing three sets of
that's 45 and 45 is 90 and 45's 135
pounds i'm putting on this shoulder
i did it yesterday i don't feel any pain
or nothing
i'm trying to continue this nice slow
pace i mean i literally started this
rehab at the beginning of
um this whole pandemic thing and i was
just doing
sets of three with the weight of my arm
no no
dumbbell or anything in there so uh i'm
up to the purple and the red weight i
got
a purple two pounder in a red one
pounder gradually getting this thing and
it feels [ __ ]
great and i was on instagram i was on
the gram guys oh my god
and uh i somehow
you know i stay away from the workout
videos
because if you click out on one workout
video your entire search thing becomes a
bunch of [ __ ]
have you noticed that if you click on
one if you click on one that's a guy
there's gonna be a bunch of [ __ ] after
that you go right back to the next
screen
and all it is is chicks with like barely
any clothes on
exercising that always involves like
bending over
or the cam being shot up the camera
being shot up their [ __ ] ass crack
all right so i don't click on any of
that [ __ ]
because once it gets on your [ __ ]
feed
you have to not click on any of it
for like it feels like [ __ ] 10 days
before it goes away
so you know what i'm actually going to
look at my phone right now i'll see what
i got here
this is actually an interesting thing
why don't you guys send me these in if
you click the magnifying glass
this search what do you end up getting
do you get workout [ __ ]
uh see what i got i got a kid playing
guitar
i got eric clapton and dwayne allman
i got tommy lee and bobby blotzer giving
the finger
this is just all music who's this that's
mick and keith
classic rock
there's tommy lee nikki six there's a
cute little puppy
there's a stand-up comic
for some reason there's something with
these three chicks
on a talk show i don't know what that is
in a ferrari video some guy driving a
ferrari that looks like a tractor looks
like a truck
the [ __ ] is this guy doing stevie ray
vaughan
yeah so i don't have any of the workout
[ __ ] here
some sort of octopus going into a clam
shell to be closed
and muhammad ali talking to john lennon
there you go that's pretty good huh i
got a picture of travis roy there
the uh rest in peace one yeah that's all
right some eddie van halen [ __ ]
so there you go that's where i'm at but
today i was on there
and you know you click on one of them
right the muhammad ali [ __ ] john
lennon and then you just start scrolling
through it and somehow it got into like
before and after pictures working out
and i saw a couple of guys that were
like in their 50s and they got
[ __ ] shredded and their before
picture is worse than i look now so
if i can just get this [ __ ] shoulder
rehab
i'm gonna be that creepy old shredded
guy
you know the guy with like like the red
chest
that [ __ ] red and brown tinged
like uh leathery skin
you know because he's from that old
generation that went out in the sun with
they put like baby oil on um
i was at the very end of that going out
into the sun
like chicks in my grade would put baby
oil on and then have like that [ __ ]
that aluminum foil thing like getting it
to the sun to reflect off it and then
just [ __ ] literally cook your face
to a nice medium well and then oh my god
i'm wearing my [ __ ]
white on white outfit coming back on
monday
look at his look at his brown as a belt
um so
anyway yeah that's uh
it's kind of a goal of mine and i really
have to just make sure that i don't plow
through this next thing because
my shoulder is getting like so much
stronger than it was so now i'm really
getting excited to like
keep adding two reps each time and i'm
sort of blowing through the three pound
reps and i'm like i got to be careful
with that [ __ ] so but it hasn't been
talking to me at all
um so we shall she shall she
shall see all right let me do uh
let me do a little [ __ ] some reads
here all right
let me do a little couple of reads here
oh look who it is everybody
look who it is me undies i ain't wearing
a [ __ ] master doo
doo doo d's behind these liberals take
me to a task
going trick-or-treating breathing on the
candy
i gave kovit to my redneck friend named
andy
i don't give a [ __ ] about any of this
[ __ ]
and my balls feel nice and soft with me
undies
uh hi friends my undies believes that
comfort is about
there's never been a redneck named andy
andy griffith
maybe i don't hi friends biondies
believes that comfort is more about
what's touching your skin um
is more than about what's touching me
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin
oh my god is this underwear going to
make me finally accept who i really am
uh you're a total badass no you're not
you could possibly be let's just give
out trophies to everybody be
undies all right i'm not gonna be
negative here you are a total badass and
what you wear should only accentuate
that fact
me undies truly believes in empowering
self-expression
um so what is badass underwear is that
like you draw a dick instead of a helmet
there's a fist on it like
like it's giving you an uppercut with
his [ __ ] [ __ ] and father there i
don't know
their pledge for 2020 and beyond is
called biundi's gives
an initiative that supports those who
have systematic barriers to
self-expression
by shopping meundies you support causes
such as the
lgbtq plus communities mental health and
well-being and women's
rights
you got anything else in there
about uh the [ __ ] prostate cancer
guys something for the for the guys in
there nothing
i guess mental health there we go
meundies are available in a range of
sizes from extra small
to 4xl um
you know something can you imagine if in
your life you just get me undies and you
go from extra small to 4xl can you
imagine doing something like that
meundies believes you and your butt
deserve comfort inside and out which is
why they created the myandi's membership
it's just it's really just a great way
to love on yourself each
month replenish your basics with styles
that are anything but basic
styles that let you be the truest
version of yourself right down to your
core
plus enjoying discounted pricing
controlled shipping
and exclusive early access meundies has
a great offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
percent off any
and free shipping myani's also has their
problem-free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason the refund or exchange it
no caveats no questions
uh to get 15 off your first order and
free shipping go to meundies.com
that's meundies.com
all right my bookie hey how the [ __ ] you
doing uh
ever since i started out people been
asking me for advice on all kinds of
things but in covering sports it's
usually about who's going to win
and what team they should bet on you got
the patriots of 49ers this week
bucks are raiders they're raiders uh
well the best place
uh piece of advice i can give to anyone
is where you're betting is just as
important as who you're betting on
it's why i always tell people to visit
my bookie
they got deposit matches free bets and
huge cash prizes
for you to take advantage of all season
long
nfl action check college ball check
plus they have a mobile friendly website
and top of the line in customer service
making the platform
a one-stop shop for all your betting
needs my bookie offers
action on everything from championship
futures
to nfl in-game live betting what are
championship
futures that's interesting uh making
sure you've covered every step
uh you're covered every step of the way
congrats if you were one of the ones to
cash in on the very generous
early season odds on the lakers to win
an nba championship
sign up at mabuki today and when you do
use your our promo code bird claim a
deposit match
dollar for dollar all the way up to a
thousand bucks it's a bonus designed to
give you a little help
and a head start on your winning season
that's promo code bird for your claim
your bonus
uh for you to claim your bonus sorry
when you make your deposit
stacked ufc cards presidential prop bets
uh all the major sports and more await
you sign up today to begin your winning
season
exclusively at my bookie oh look who it
is indochino
uh finding clothes that fit you just
right can be incredibly challenged
challenging describe any issue well you
know what i have back fat but it's only
on one side of my back and i just can't
find a shirt that fits me in a in a
flattering way
describe any fit issues you run into
when you're shopping for clothing
um you know i got this little [ __ ] belly
you know and i don't i don't feel
comfortable wearing a cummerbund i don't
know what to do about
talk about how you feel when you find
clothing that fits you just right well i
just feel like a superstar
indochito suit are great for weddings
and work
and they even offer casual options like
shirts coats and chinos
with indochino you get custom fitted
suits coats and casual wear at
surprisingly
affordable prices customize everything
from fabric to the lining to the to the
lapel
shape and monogram and since you i love
the monogram dude come on that's old
school [ __ ] right there
an old school man you know he had
monogrammed shirts
right he has initials in there like he
was some uh
robber baron in the 1800s saying i owed
the public nothing
you know had a nice little handkerchief
so when he
he broke up with his check he could dry
her [ __ ] eyes before he kicked her
ass out of his uh
his uh what is the ice delivery truck
his ice chest truck smoke cigars all
right bill get back customize everything
from the fabric lining to the lapel
shape and the monogram and since your
order is made to your exact measurements
it always fits you perfectly unless you
chow down after you order it um if
you're getting married maddie
geez indochino is no-brainer for you and
your groomsmen
forget off-the-rack suits that that fit
that don't fit different body types
indochino gives
everyone a tailored fit order with ease
and get it get it shipped fast no matter
where you live
and you will always uh and with all the
ways to customize you can add personal
touches everyone will be proud to wear
without
emptying their pockets the best part is
indochino suits start at just 299
with all customizations included visit
one of the indochinos showrooms across
north america
or book a virtual appointment and shop
online at indochino.com and right now
you can get 30 off any purchase of 3.99
no more when you enter code your code
bur bur
at checkout that's indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code and lastly
but not leastly the
last read last read for love
um hello fresh hello fresh
offers convenient delivery right to your
doorstep for easy home cooking with the
family
the recipes are easy to follow and quick
to make with simple steps
and pictures to guide you along the way
hellofresh
cuts out stressful meal planning and
grocery store trips
so you can enjoy cooking and get dinner
on the table
in about 30 minutes or even less you can
save 40 percent
by using hello fresh versus shopping at
your local grocery store
and it's more convenient too there's
something for everyone including
low-calorie vegetarian and kid-friendly
recipes
uh we enjoyed our box all the recipes
were easy to follow and extremely
satisfying
the the gouda burgers were delicious
and the prep was super easy hello fresh
delivers fresh
high quality pre-portioned ingredients
so you can make meals
that are delicious and nutritious hello
fresh streamlined
supply chain means per produce gets to
you faster
and fresher than the grocery store
feeding the whole family has never been
easier with the larger boxes
box sizes for more servings and more
helping hello fresh
donated over 2.5 million meals to
charity in 2019 and this year they're
stepping up
food donations to local communities amid
the coronavirus crisis isn't that nice
um all right go to hellofresh.com
billbert80 and use the code billbird80
to get a total
of eighty dollars off across five boxes
including free shipping on your first
box that's hellofresh.com
billbert80 and use code uh use the code
billbert
b-e-r-t billbert 80 to get a total of
eighty dollars off across
five boxes including free shipping on
your first box
all right here we go let's get into the
questions everybody
um being vote shamed
all right before i read this if you
don't tell people who you're voting for
there's no way to be shamed all right i
want to start a movement where somebody
asks you who you're voting for
you you should say you should just tell
them that that's rude
i don't answer rude questions like that
how dare you how about you just go how
dare you
how dare you what are you taking a
[ __ ] survey
all right uh well as a matter of fact i
am
oh really and is my vote in your little
circle of the [ __ ] world going to
make you
have a good prediction of who's going to
win or lose
all right being vote-shamed dear billy
the wise
wise ass uh this
this is the first elect i like that
if i was a wrestler that's that's what i
would if i was a manager
billy the wise wise ass uh this is the
first election
i'm able to vote in congratulations i'm
20 years old and i've been listening to
you since i was 13.
oh jesus uh i would load your podcast
onto an ipod and listen on the bus to
school i really appreciate you not
regurgitating everything
i heard elsewhere in my life you're a
renaissance man whether you like it or
not
uh i got these young kids fooled uh
you know i appreciate that you know you
live a little more life you'll be like
nah this he's just sort of the loud guy
at a bar
um i read a lot and listen to
non-mainstream media that's great
i re
i think he meant to say i recently
i i read
i don't know it says i i've r e a and i
know what it says after that i'm just
gonna continue
i've made my own judgment about how
debilitating
the establishment is toward our country
the news does not tell us
what is really going on with our
country's finances and foreign affairs
this cycle has been going on for decades
and i don't want to be a part of it i'm
voting for a third party candidate
whose principles i agree with my friends
are telling me that i'm wasting my vote
and i cannot can afford to do it because
i'm privileged
which is why i have the audacity to do
something like that
um oh cause they're not white and they
need you to vote
the way they want you to vote
all right aside from that stuff there i
i don't think voting for a third party
person that you believe in that is
actually an honest person and will
hopefully stand up to the banks
in the oil companies
um without getting whacked i don't think
that is ever a waste
and i always believe that you're
encouraging more people like that to run
for office
um
as far as what your friends are saying
it sounds like they're not white
if they're saying that stuff i got to be
honest it's it's
the uh
the guy who's in office right now is
making them feel that way
which is what blows my mind about some
friends that i have
that are voting for trump and they're
like i i just don't
show me an example of how he's racist
is like how they look at it and it's
just like well
do you have any black friends
i i don't know what to tell what
speeches are you watching
um i can just tell you this
my biggest advice that i would give you
is just don't tell people who you're
voting for and you know if your heart's
in the right place and you're voting
for what you want to vote for then
there's nothing wrong whoever with
whoever you're voting for
okay straight across the board democrat
republic libertarian third party
whatever the [ __ ] you call it i don't
just
somewhere along the line people just
started saying who the [ __ ] they were
voting for liberals
celebrities um
you know i don't know let me just
continue reading this uh my mother lost
her business was i was in middle school
and we had to live with my uncle when
the economy crashed and she lost
everything it wasn't her fault her
landlord went bankrupt and the bank sold
the building to an investment group
that used a loophole to condemn the
building put her out of business to end
her lease
and then rented it out at twice the
price the following year
those [ __ ] people are brutal this has
informed a lot of my views and i don't
apologize for it
despite being told i should it's really
unfair to be talked to like this
especially when the people telling me
this have no understanding of things
beyond what they read in the headlines
on twitter
i know you voted third party in the past
has anyone your family
or colleagues ever try to make you feel
guilty for your beliefs absolutely i've
always been told that i've been
you know throwing away my vote and stuff
like that
um but you know you are privileged
if you're white it's just a fact you
just are
and just le i'm just going to tell you
my point of view on this like
people misconstrue what that means
it's like oh you know we lost a house we
were broke we went through this you went
through that
my dad died that's
like not what that's about it means you
can drive
down the street and not have to worry
that you're going to get pulled over
because of you the color of your skin
and maybe lose your life it's like that
story i told you when my brother-in-law
was driving across country
and i was talking to him like he was a
white guy going you got to do route 66
and check out the [ __ ] you know the
arch in st
louis and my wife ripped the phone out
of my hand
and had literally fear in her voice
then all my brother-in-law was going to
do was drive across the country
and she was like was saying
only drive on the highways only drive
during the day
drive the speed limit because she was
worried that he was going to get
killed just driving across the country
so that's what they mean
i used to think privilege i mean were
you talking about i didn't know
i [ __ ] paid for 90 of my college
i i [ __ ] worked my way through
college i
got in this business i didn't know
anybody but that's not what they're
saying it's it's how you move through
the world
um is what it is it's not your your
how much money you had or if you went to
a private school or not it just means
that
you don't have to basically
worry that you're going to get killed
by your own your fellow country man just
for [ __ ]
how you look that's what it means all
right there you go
and i believe to fund the police doesn't
mean don't [ __ ] pay them
or get rid of them as far as i
understand it
somebody please give a clear definition
what i understand of it is we kind of
stop dumping all the mistakes of society
onto cops and have them deal with the
[ __ ] every day
like why are cops dealing with mentally
ill people they should be in
institutions getting cared for
instead of having the cops have to deal
with that on top of all the other [ __ ]
they have to [ __ ] deal with
so i think that that's what it meant and
for whatever stupid [ __ ] reason they
said called it defunding which sounds to
me like hey pay him
less or don't pay him which is insane
um almost as insane as me
tackling these huge topics here all
right policy doesn't create
opposition opposition creates policy
what the [ __ ]
got to read this 12 times policy doesn't
create opposition
opposition create policies
okay i gotta take a sip of throat coat t
here before i read this one
i could read that a thousand [ __ ]
times and i would never know what it
means
um hello bill i am an admirer of yours
and i think you put in a positive
contribution
to u.s pop culture um
all right that was the most
condescending first line ever
i think you put in a positive
contribution to you as pop culture
oh do you is that what you think
i don't
i just think i'm an idiot that a certain
segment listens to for whatever reason
uh i think my subject lines up with your
philosophy
in quotes or at least it doesn't
contradict it
i don't even know what you do you're
you're beyond me mentally i don't know
what that means policy doesn't create
opposition
opposition creates policy
this is like chicken or the egg so if
you pose some
oppose something they create a policy to
make it to outlaw
opposing it is that what you're saying i
don't know can you expand on the idea
that people don't really have
genuine political opinions but rather
have an innate propensity to get into
arguments
and that this is really what 99 of
political debate in the u.s
and everywhere else and at every other
time has been
like if my parents are liberals i'm
likely to be a conservative just to piss
them off and vice versa
and if i'm not what kind of a [ __ ] am i
you know what i mean no because if you
had parents that you liked
i think your parents are [ __ ] you
just you do stuff like that
anyway people are way less rational and
way more emotional
in comprehension confrontational just
for the hell of it right
uh i don't you're speaking vaguely or
above my [ __ ] brain i don't know what
you're saying here
um i will say that you know most
discourse is that the right word has
just begun people screaming at each
other
which i've done a couple of my relatives
about politics and
and i said like 12 times during it we're
not going to change each other's this is
such a [ __ ] waste of time
and you still do it um
i don't know no matter what happens
tomorrow i i'm
just gonna i don't know if i can have
half the vibe
that travis roy had when i met him that
one time i think i i
you can really
the world a better place
despite if you don't like
the person that's currently your your
leader
you know what i mean i actually saw
something [ __ ] amazing today i was
watching i turned on the tv and a
preacher was on
and he was really good and i was
listening to him
and he was saying the sum of your life
and the impact that you have comes right
down to basically the choices you make
and if you make positive choices
loving choices that's the impact you're
going to have
on the world and i was like oh my god i
love this guy i found a church
and then he goes and when you accept
jesus christ i'm like why do they always
have to do that
why can't they just stop right there
before they introduce their guy
that separates everybody
if you just accept this if you just did
every every religion has a [ __ ] guy
or a lady maybe that i don't maybe they
don't have a lady and then just
just just stop right there
because do i do i need to know the guy
if i did everything that the that you
just [ __ ] told me to do right before
the jesus
christ [ __ ] even if i didn't wasn't
aware of jesus if the guy
existed and and is really the son of god
and i'm gonna [ __ ] meet the guy
i mean if i don't know who the [ __ ] he
is but i lived a great life and i spread
love and positivity and i help people
out
and had a positive effect i'm still
getting in the club right
i don't [ __ ]
i was literally watching the tv going
like holy [ __ ]
i finally found my 700 club guy that i
can
i can get into this and when you accept
christ it's just like yeah i don't need
that
i just need the first part now you're
having me choose teams
in every religion people say what that
guy says and then
it gets to that fork in the [ __ ] road
and then it's
uh yahweh allah god
buddha and they just and then that just
somehow it it divides people
what a surprise right what a surprise
people just start arguing and then they
[ __ ] kill each other
just i don't know we're morons all right
advice
changing people around me hi bill big
fan of you
and your show i've spent much of my
covet time listening and reopening my
eyes to the manipulative rhetoric being
spewed about
men that i unfortunately have
contributed
at least during my early adult years as
a result i notice a lot of women
my boyfriend is surrounded by whether
it's because they are friends or
girlfriends of his
treat men and their men like garbage
jesus christ is this actually a woman
writing this
this feels almost like i wrote it
because of this i don't feel comfortable
being around them because when i try to
stick up for their guys
when they do nice things they laugh at
me and then put me down
it sounds to me like you're hanging out
with [ __ ] my question
for you is how do i open the eyes of the
women around me to the negativity
they are exhibiting towards their
significant others without stepping over
the line
you can't you can't and you're smart
enough to at least ask the question
before you try to do it
just don't do it don't do it and
hopefully those guys will be smart
enough to try to find a woman like
yourself
if the way you're presenting yourself is
true uh
she goes on to say i don't like seeing
these women complain
and pick on their men when they do
everything for their women including
cooking cleaning
fixing things uh i think in their
eyes i must come across as very
traditional but i think
treating your significant other the same
way you want to be treated
if not better is a sign of your
upbringing and what kind of person you
want to be in this world i
100 agree every man i have had in my
life
has made me the person i am today so why
would i want to stunt the growth and
progress
of people around me by exerting my
insecurities and taking it out on them
all right this is this is written by a
unicorn
male or female the enlightenment of this
um i don't know how to bring this up to
my boyfriend either because i don't want
to disrespect him by pointing out that
the women he surrounds himself with
are not good examples of what a woman
should be
wait so your boyfriend's hanging out
with all these other broads what are
they nagging him they're nagging their
wait a minute are you are you just
talking about the girlfriends of all of
his friends
are you competing with them what's going
on now i don't know what's going on
my theory as to why they act like they
do
they they act wait my theory as to why
they act like this may have to do with
the fact that many of the theme
of his female friends are really unhappy
in their lives either because they can't
bear children or are in unfulfilling
relationships and careers
ah this is starting to come off as i
don't know how do i show them that
inner peace and love for all is how you
live a full and happy life
many thanks wise fellow ginger
sage um
all right if you're the nice person
you're presenting
rather than someone who's just being
petty and competitive with the
girlfriends of your boyfriend's
friends um you just keep your mouth
shut okay
this this is not a problem for you to
solve
it's none of your business and just stay
out of it
or you can create a giant [ __ ] show
by getting in the middle of it you know
there's no [ __ ] way
there's there's no way there's no way to
do that
all right so
uh i don't know if you're hanging out
with them and they're [ __ ]
bitching about their boyfriends i mean
why do you have to hang out with them
anyway why the [ __ ] do you hang out with
go get your go get some
people who look at life the way you do
and hang out with them rather than
hanging out with these fixer-uppers that
you can't fix up because they think the
way they're living is right
um does that make sense i don't know all
right
we have a new category here in the
monday morning podcast of uh people who
work
with the general public we have uh a top
five dumb questions
top five dumb questions people have
asked you
whether you work at one of the few
blockbuster videos left
or if you know i don't know you you work
at a [ __ ] starbucks all right so
here's this person wrote in top five
dumb questions
school volunteer hey bill
i'm a female i love when the ladies
write in i'm a female college student
that volunteers at local schools in my
free time
and let me tell you teens are dumb as
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was grading tests for a health class
a question asked students to define
unsafe sex
and one kid wrote sex during a hurricane
now that has to be the class clown
nobody could be that dumb
and not funny and not not you know
and that can't be on that has to be on
purpose all right we had a tornado drill
at the school
in which the regular procedure is to
have students
get into a windowless secure room
one teacher mistook the alarm for a fire
drill
and brought the students outside
oh boy there's one girl with hippy dippy
parents that always want
me to admit the earth is
flat one day she tried to disprove axial
rotation axle rotation by saying if
time zones were real california
would have warned hawaii about pearl
harbor
what the [ __ ]
wow dude
it's that that well that's a
that is so dumb i got dumber reading
that going like
no wait you're going the wrong way then
i was like no they are going the right
way because they would be ahead of time
that is so [ __ ] up so pearl harbor
would be on the news
in california before it happened in
hawaii so then they could say hey man
we're three hours in the future so we
just to give you a heads up the japanese
are coming
wow that one takes the cake so far
uh hippie dippy flat earth girl also
once said to me
if we can really go to space how come
astronauts have never been to earth
i don't even know what that means uh i
was
moderating a debate on gender norms
between
a dill weed and a stoner i don't know
what dill weed is a dil
dilweed asked how come only men
have to take paternity tests no one asks
a mother to prove that a baby is hers
jesus
all right um fyi most of these kids are
really sweet and will probably do great
things someday except for a hippie dippy
flat earth girl i predict she'll drop
out within a few years thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself
wow all right here we go top five dumb
questions we've got a pilot
nice i'm a 24 year old pilot for a
commercial airline look at this
person crushing life they used to fly
corporate
and i wanted to share my top five dumb
ass dumbest questions
from the general public slash celebrity
community
uh are you sure you guys can handle the
wind
at the time i'm 21 still baby-faced and
supposed to be flying this 40-year
old typical hard-headed masshole from
boston to the vineyard just for dinner
he had his 85 year old mother and his
wife and his nine-year-old daughter
the winds were gusting to 40 knots in
moderate to heavy
turbulence forecasted i warned him that
i was it was going to be unpleasant and
maybe they should reschedule
he said to me uh you could be my son
are you sure you can handle the wind
okay so he's saying you're young and
it's okay to have concerns about this so
far it seems all right
i responded with i'm not worried about
my abilities i just don't know if this
is the kind of experience your daughter
would want to experience oh yeah jesus
christ why would you do that
to your kid fast forward 30 minutes
later i've never been more excited to
hear the sound of four people puking in
my life
the other pilot and i looked at each
other and all we had to do was smile
needless to say they spent the night at
the vineyard and we left
can't you just fly above the wind
similar situations to the one above i
thought aren't they asking for smoother
air i don't know
are you sure the weather isn't bad
[Music]
my brother says it's nice at his house
in danvers
the guy proceeds to show me a picture on
his phone of blue sky that he
got sent from his brother rvr
was down to about 400
feet what does that mean i don't rvr is
that cloud cover
jesus christ wait a minute i got to see
so i got to look this up
aviation rvr
runway visual range was down to 400 feet
oh my god
okay
uh where it's baggage claim i look above
my head and there's a big yellow sign
that says baggage claim
uh do you even fly the airplane
uh parentheses i'm a first officer ah
yeah
we take turns each leg really
i just thought you sat there in case the
captain dies
right yikes dude these are great
these are great from your fellow new
englander and irishmen i love the
podcast and always listen
on long sits between flights hope you
get on a flight
and the little ones can come up and nerd
out up in the cockpit p.s
helicopters are way harder to fly than
airplanes
as always go [ __ ] yourself um
that's amazing jesus christ
can't you just fly above the wind all
right top five dumb questions
9-1-1 e-m-t okay i like how we
the way these are set up andrew how you
got these basically
each job gets more and more intense all
right
hello mr burb hello mr burr big fan
long time podcast listener thank you i
know you are asking for the top five
stupid questions
but i am sharing with you my top five
stupid reasons why the public has called
now okay
that's okay you can adjust it you can
improv here
top five reasons the public is called
911 is an emergency
i've been an ambulance operator for
close to three years and have my stories
but these
are the top five number five wife called
9-1-1
because her husband was eating dog food
gross i know he was apparently trying to
tell her
that her cooking was [ __ ] he would
rather eat dog food
this wasn't a handful of kibble neither
it was straight out of the can
wet dog food wow number four
man called 9-1-1 because he was choking
on food
all right well if he can talk that means
he's not choking he can breathe right
well you might think that that
that is an emergency call but here is
the twist he was
choking the day before and called 9-1-1
to have us
explain to him why he was choking
he wanted us to take him to the
emergency room so the doctor could
explain to him
the medical reason why he was choking on
food
this was a 40 year old man
what the [ __ ] these these are making me
feel better about myself
number three a woman called electricity
out five minutes ago we advise her to
call the electric company
[Laughter]
number two a woman called 9-1-1 because
she wanted
us two emts to force her two daughters
to help her clean the house
these daughters looked to be in their
late 20s in her defense
the house was very dirty
wow number one a man called 9-1-1
because his mom is too fat
when we arrived he asked us to give his
mother medication that will somehow
magically
melt her fat away forever that's in
quotes
these kinds of calls makes for good
stories but takes us away from the
public that actually needs us
when seconds counts anyway big fan and
congratulations on your beautiful family
your friend on the booboo bus that's
great the boo boo bust
um all right anyway so that is the uh
that's the podcast you know i caught a
little bit of that cowboys
eagles game cowboys came showed up to
play
uh looks like the eagles were pulling
away towards the end i didn't catch the
end of the game but uh
a lot of great games this week so hey
let's look at the standings man let's
who do you who do you like here
is there a favorite for the super bowl
um let's see this is a stat leader
aviation
nfl standings your buffalo bills six and
two
at the top of the afc east uh
dolphins four and three patriots two and
five
the jets oh and eight
oh and eight the chiefs seven and one
still have to be you gotta you know to
be the man you gotta beat the man the
chiefs
are the defending super bowl champions
so
you got to figure that they are the
odds-on favorite to repeat
uh radius four and three broncos three
and four the chargers
been losing some close ones two and five
the funnest two and five team you're
ever
gonna watch by the way i love watching
the chargers uh
the pittsburgh steelers seven and oh
the only undefeated team left ravens
five and two
browns five and three bengals two and
five who by the way beat
the [ __ ] titans today joe barrow
um mike frable great coach titans five
and two
colts five and two texans one and six
uh jaguars one and six with my favorite
quarterback
gardner-mitchu um the old-school
throwback do
mustache the [ __ ] mullet you gotta
love the guy you gotta love the guy and
i think his team's better than their
record
all right the eagles three and four
uh cowboys two sorry the
washington football team two and five
cowboys two and six
giants one and six
unbelievable as of today the the the
team in first place in the nfc east had
only won
two games and the giants were still a
game out i mean that's just [ __ ]
ridiculous
um it's just a weird what happened to
that division where everybody
is sort of has a new quarterback or
injured new coaches and just
all starting over
it's amazing somebody's going to win
that division
um and still make the playoffs playoffs
seahawks six and one cardinals five and
two rams five and three
49ers four and four packers five and two
bears five and three lions three and
four vikings two and five and the saints
five and two buccaneers five and two
panthers [ __ ]
three and five falcons two and six all
right
my pick for the the uh
nfc championship is i'm gonna say the
seattle seahawks
are gonna go up against uh
um i'm literally looking at
points against with the packers and the
saints
although the buccaneers have a stingy
defense
only giving up 142 points i don't know
i definitely see seattle
i see them uh i see them in the super
[ __ ] this [ __ ] the
the championship i see the seattle
seahawks in the super bowl
versus i think uh
kansas city goes there again
and and
did they let me just think who they got
who do they got they got all the
offensive weapons
then you got pete carroll i think pete
carroll goes back and gets the ring
i think he prevents the chiefs from
going back to back
i think he gets his second ring and he
definitely doesn't retire the guy's got
like [ __ ] zero percent body fat he's
a [ __ ] animal
and he's never gonna be satisfied
and he's just gonna keep going so that's
why i'm picking the seattle seahawks to
win the whole [ __ ] thing
all right there you heard it from me you
heard it here first now who am i rooting
for that's a different story
i'm rooting for tom brady and the tampa
bay
uh buccaneers rob gronkowski i'm rooting
for those guys
although i got to tell you i also like
uh
kyler murray in the arizona cardinals
they're fun as hell to watch
and uh just a lot of fun teams this year
to watch
and like i said the chargers the most
fun two and five team you ever going to
watch i love watching the cleveland
browns i thought the cleveland browns
and raiders was going to be a wild game
today it looked like it was pretty
pedestrian
i taped a bunch of games i'm going to
watch them throughout the week as i do
so i get to watch nfl football
every [ __ ] night because i love it
i'm addicted to it i'm a simple guy
you know i don't go that deep i'm not a
big reader what else am i going to do
other than sit here watching bread and
circus
all right that's the podcast uh thank
you guys for listening once again
rest in peace to one of the most amazing
people i ever met and lived an
incredible life travis roy
and i'll be reaching out to their
foundation to uh hopefully next year do
a mask-free show
post covid and um to continue
all the great work that that incredible
foundation that he started uh
has done throughout the years to
continue it um
for as long as i can help out that's it
all right go [ __ ] yourselves and i will
check in on you on thursday